Jim, here. *newsflash music*
We managed to steal the
secret seer's mystical supplies.
Just got in a dark place near where he was killed.
The man in the manor, whoever he was.
We will find the answer to this puzzle, Jim.
But be very Jim.
We have to be careful in here.
There are unknown forces lurking amongst us.
Look at that face, on the wall.
You see the demons within us!
You see the demons without us! *thump*
Oww, Jim hurt Jim footsie!
*inaudible*
I feel the spirits working up a storm in here, Jim.
Come, come Jim.
There's not much time.
We have to lay out exactly what we need
to be able to summon an answer
to this puzzle.
All right.
Spirits of this world.
Speak through me.
I'm Jim.
This is Jim.
Jim is our family name.
And Jim must get an answer.
Where...is...
the killer?
K I P
L
I E R
AAAH! It's DEMONS!
Run, Jim!
Ruuuuuun! Ruuun!
*static*